all right
next question
a lot of seven adventists believe that
wearing jewelry example earrings chains
are not a sin
and that they can wear them
some also believe that body tattoos are
not sin
what does god say
all right
i knew trouble was coming soon
let's pray
father give us a heart to receive
biblical truth
and not social customs
in jesus name i pray amen
go to genesis 3.
we read verse six and verse seven
well let's read from one to seven read
the bible
genesis three one to seven we're talking
about ornaments and decorations on the
outside all that stuff we call jewelry
which is such a big business
do you have it
now the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the lord god
had made
and he said unto the woman yea hath god
said he shall not eat of every tree of
the garden
and a woman said unto the serpent we may
eat of the fruit of the trees of the
garden
but of the fruit of the tree which is in
the midst of the garden god has said he
shall not eat of it neither shall he
touch it lest ye die
and the serpent said unto the woman ye
shall not surely die for god doth know
that in the day ye eat thereof then your
eyes shall be opened and ye shall be as
god's knowing good and evil verse six
and when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food which it was not by the
way and that was pleasant to the eyes
and a tree to be desired to make one
wise she took of the fruit thereof and
did eat and gave also unto her husband
with her and he did it now verse 8 and
the eyes of them both were up verse 7
and they knew that they were naked and
they sewed fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons what was made in verse
what
what was made
be specific
aprons of
please let's go to verse 21.
read for me
unto adam also and to his wife did the
lord god make coats of skins and clothe
them okay i want to draw some of your
attention
what was made on the first day
too slow too slow too slow live second
day
firm third day
it is an adventist church
fourth day
sun moon and stars fifth day
birds and fish sixth day land animals
and human beings question for you what
did adam and eve make
in that week of creation
nothing
nothing all the making the creating was
done by god
go back to genesis 3 7.
we're looking at a principle
a negative principle
read verse 7 again
and the eyes of them both were opened
and they knew that they were naked stop
read verse 25 of chapter 2.
and they were both naked the man and his
wife and were not ashamed are you with
me but that was before
sin
after sin
they're ashamed
so what are they trying to deal with
the embarrassment the shame the guilt
that's what they're trying to handle
how do they handle it
they made a prince of leaves
now that's the first thing the bible
records a human being ever made on the
earth
something to cover where
the outside
are you not listening to me
something to beautify
the outside something to help me feel a
little better about myself
are you with me
with this principle in mind
now
let's go to zechariah 3
zechariah 3
are you there
not yet
come on come on find zechariah find
malachi then work your way back malachi
okay you got it now
you're sure
i said zechariah
you have zechariah
chapter 3
what's the first word in there
and he showed me joshua the high priest
come on standing before the angel of the
lord and satan standing at his right
hand to resist him
keep reading and he
unto satan the lord rebuked thee o satan
even the lord that have chosen jerusalem
rebuke thee is not this a brand plucked
out of the fire verse three now joshua
was clothed with filthy garments stop
describe the leaves
safety garments because god had to
remove them
are you following me filthy garments now
joshua's clothed with filthy garments
and stood before the angel keep reading
and he answered and speaking to those
that stood before him saying what take
away the filthy garments from him and to
him he said behold i have caused that
iniquity to pass from thee and i will
clothe thee with change of raymond now
in joshua we have a symbol of how god
functions he removes that man-made stuff
and replaces it with the symbol of the
righteousness of his son are you with me
now let's go back to genesis
genesis 3 21 keep the information from
zechariah 3 verse 1 to four let's go to
genesis 3 verse 21 unto adam also
and to his wife did the lord god make
coats of skins and clothe them before he
put the skins on what did he have to
remove those aprons of leaves man-made
for the purpose of feeling better
reducing a sense of guilt and shame
now to see how worthless the aprons were
let's go to verse 8 of genesis 3
and they heard the voice of the lord god
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day and adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the lord god
amongst the trees of the garden now why
are they hiding if they're already
covered
because there's no human covering that
can improve your appearance in the sight
of god are you following me
no you're not following me
verse 21 coats of skin the blood of
christ
is what needs to cover us now having
said all of that
let us go to
exodus
exodus no genesis 35
it's 10 after seven when does the sunset
eat what
temperance and all things temperance
temperance okay
we're going to genesis 35
we're even verse 1
let me pray father as we continue please
lord teach us we want to know
because salvation is knowledge
teach us their god in the name of jesus
christ i pray amen now let me set this
up for you in chapter 34 simeon and levi
kill all the men in the city
because the prince of that city had
raped their sister jacob had 13 children
12 boys and one girl
you know that girl who can be protected
when she was raped simeon and levi went
to the city and said to the prince look
you defiled our sister
you have to marry her.
the prince said yeah i'll marry you.
but the boy said you can't marry her
because you're uncircumcised
the person said we'll get circumcised so
simian levi the servants came in
circumcised all the men
waited three days for them to be
properly immobile are you following me
then came with the swords
and killed
all the men
brought the women into captivity and the
children all the possession of the city
and in the field and took it all away
and when this terrible thing happened
jacob said the surrounding tribes will
kill me because i'm just a small group
now god is going to get them out of this
are you following me he's getting them
out of this crisis that's what we're
about to read verse 1 genesis 35 and god
said unto jacob arise
go up bethel and dwell there and make
there an altar unto god that appeared
unto thee when thou fled is from the
face of esau thy brother remember jacob
running from esau okay
verse two
then jacob said unto his household and
to all that with him
put away the strange gods that are among
you and be clean and change your
garments this is a spiritual change
you've offended god
changes have to be made get rid of
strange gods
be clean change your garments now verse
three what does that say
and let us arise and go up to bethel and
i will make the an altar unto god that
what answered me in the day of my
distress
and which was with me in the way which i
went
now
jacob said in first two put over the
strange gods be clean change your
garments verse four read with me now and
they gave unto jacob all the strange
gods which were in their hands and all
the earrings which were in their ears
and jacob hid them under the oak which
was by shechem
now all the jewelry
jacob took
and buried it
go to matthew 25.
matthew 25 we'll read from verse 14.
are you with me
you have matthew 25
verse 14.
okay you say yes but you're still
turning pages all right okay
okay
are we there now can i rely on that yes
okay read with me for the kingdom of is
as a man traveling into a far country
who called his own servants and
delivered unto them his goods next verse
and until one he gave five talents to
another two and to another one to every
man according to his several abilities
and straight away took his journey now
next verse 16 i think it is now he that
had received the five talents went and
traded with the same and made them other
five talents likewise he that had
received two he also gained other two
read verse 18
went and digged in the earth and hid his
lord's money what did jacob do with the
jewelry
in the earth what does this man do with
a talon
signifying what
how did the fellow with five get ten
what did he do
yes he traded he used it are you with me
are you following he used it got went
from five to ten what about the fella
who went from two to four he used it
he put it to use
the fella with one what did he do
he buried it meaning what
he didn't use it
what did jacob do with that jewelry
he buried it it was not to be
used
go to exodus
33. exodus 33
we have another crisis the israelites
are full of crises we have another
crisis
these people have just worshipped the
golden calf
and god was this close to wiping them
out moses sent the levites with their
swords three thousand were killed in
that day
now god wants them to do something to
show repentance and a change of mind and
heart verse 1
exodus 33 let me know when you're there
read with me and the lord said unto
moses depart and go up hence thou and
the people which thou has brought up out
of the land of egypt unto the land which
i swear unto abraham to isaac and to
jacob saying unto thy seed will i give
it
keep reading and i will send my angel
before thee and i will drive out the
canaanite the amorite and the hittite
then the parasite the hivite and the
jebusite now verse three unto a lamb
flowing with milk and honey keep reading
for i will not go up in the midst of
thee for ye are without
naked people lest i consume you in the
way god is saying i am so mad
i don't want to travel with you
in your condition because i'll just
destroy you
is god love
can god get mad
is his madness just yes
verse four and when the people heard
these evil tidings come on they mourned
and no man did put on him he they
refused upon all jewry they had
verse five greeted for the lord had said
unto moses
say unto the children of israel ye are a
stiff-necked people i will come up in
the midst of thee in a moment and
consume thee therefore now put off thy
ornaments from there that i may know
what to do
unto thee
verse 6
and the children of israel strip
themselves of the ornaments by the mount
horeb now let me tell you the hebrew
rendering strip themselves by the mount
means from the mount or meaning from
that point on
they left them off
from mount horeb
they left them off subsequent travels
we have two spiritual crises and god
says you need to straighten yourself out
on each occasion get rid of all that
stuff
now
go to ezekiel 28.
let's read from verse 13. this is a
description of lucifer before he fell
are you with me
i'm not convinced you are but okay
ezekiel 28
reading from verse 13 are you there
okay some are you still looking for
ezekiel
all right i give you 10 seconds to find
ezekiel it's 7 18.
you have ezekiel 28 18 13 read with me
thou has been in eden the garden of god
every precious stone was thy covering
come on the sardius the topaz the
diamond what else the barrel
onyx the jasper what else the sapphire
the emerald the carbuncle and gold keep
reading the workmanship of thy tabriz
and of thy pies was prepared in thee in
the day that that was created who is
that lucifer
he was covered with precious stones
let's find out what his problem was go
to verse 17 and read it for me
come on
thine heart was lifted up in the y
because of thy beauty come on that has
corrupted thy wisdom by reason of thy
brightness stop
when lucifer realized how pretty he was
thine heart was lifted up in thee
because of thy beauty you know you went
to high school the most stuck up person
was the girl who thought she was the
prettiest
his outward appearance
led to his
i'm not saying his only reason but it
contributed
now
when god made lucifer he was covered
with all that stuff
when god made adam
was this sin in the world in the
universe when god made adam was this sin
in the universe yes
who would sin for lucifer are you with
me so did god know the catastrophe he
had with this pretty angel
how did he make adam give me one word
starts with n
naked
what did he have on him nothing
what did eve have on her nothing
now
does god want us to breathe
what did he give us
we're two holes are you with me
oh you're not listening
does he want us to listen
what did he give us
with holes
if he wanted us to wear earrings
you got to put another hole right here
and one right here
ah you don't like me anymore
are you listening to me
he made adam and eve with nothing on
them
a baby comes out of the woman two days
later you pound a hole in the air and
you pound them
and you drive a screwdriver through
something and you cuff some with a saw
to high metal
let me tell you some of jewelry in
ancient times
people wore them to identify with their
idols
some jewelry formed were called amulets
and amulet was devised to protect you
from evil spirits
some jewelry had markings on them that
represented the idols
and as the idols were decorated people
decorate themselves so they look like
come on they're idols
go to leviticus 19.
leviticus 19.
well i forgot to welcome those listening
online
wherever you are god bless you
and may the truth of his word reach you
unopposed
what book did i say leviticus what
chapter 19 read verse 28 microscopically
are you there and keep in mind the key
word that describes or summarizes
leviticus is
holiness
read verse 28 now
you shall make no
cuttings
in your flesh for the dead
or print
marks upon you
i am now
don't cut yourself
don't print marks on you
that's what people did to identify with
the dead and their ancestors whom they
worshipped are you following me
remember the prophets of baal
on mount carmel
with elijah when baal wouldn't answer
what does this have to do cut them no
don't do that
now
when god says don't cut yourself what
does he mean don't cut yourself don't
tell god it's a little
cute pastor they don't like what i'm
saying don't tell god but it's just a
little cut
because adam could have said it's just a
grape
that's all i consumed
why are you putting me out god said
don't do it
now to have earrings in your ear do you
have to pierce it
or some do you up here is that a cut
why are you hesitating as dory why
stammer is that a cut yes
don't make me mad
the verse says don't print any marks on
your body
are your toes a part of your body
come on tell me you don't sound sure huh
why are they red
that's a mark
now someone is saying this guy is
extreme
i'm not extreme
you either
for god
or you're not now let me say this some
people are convicted at different times
different times i was preaching
somewhere and i made a call to give up
all that jewelry people came and put
rings and on the table
and i told the head elder the pastor
sell it and give the money to the doctor
society
they took it off and put it there
mm-hmm
go to first timothy chapter two
i know someone watching me wants to kill
me but
the pastor is here to protect me he
won't let me get killed you want to kill
me i know that
i feel that heat coming from you
first timothy chapter two let's read
from verse nine
i'll miss you when i'm gone
i really will
god bless you all the days of your life
god bless you god bless you i mean it
first peter first timothy chapter two do
you have that
let me pray father as we continue
teach us god we forget quickly teach us
and soften that stony heart that does
not like what is being said in jesus
name i pray amen
first timothy 2 verse 9 says what
in like manner also that women adorn
themselves with modest power in modest
apparel with shame-facedness and
sobriety let me tell you something
modesty is almost extinct
when i was a boy you know what a modest
person looks like
modesty today is almost extinct
people in the church no longer
understand what modesty is i was coming
through johannesburg south africa and uh
oh
and i saw a lady dressed
and the moment i saw her i was impressed
with the modesty wishes
i wanted to go and tell her but as a
preacher you can't just do these things
could be misunderstood but i said lord
bless that woman you can tell she
respected herself
and she was not advertising for a man
are you following me she was just
dressed modestly covered and i i looked
at her i admired i said god bless that
woman
modesty means very little in the church
today
are you with me because our standards
are not biblical or ellen white they are
the world
finish verse 9 of first timothy 2 again
what does that say
in like manner also that women adorn
themselves in modest power with
shamefacedness and in other words you
ought to be ashamed if you walk out of
the house looking like that
come on not with
or gold or pearls or costly array now
there's controversy as to what brought
it here means that i have no position on
it but what we do know there are some
hairstyles the bible condemns are you
with me now some people were chatting
all right
whether or not you understand what
broadened hair means it does tell us
there are some hairstyles that god does
not approve of
they do not reflect christian modesty
now you can decide if yours falls under
that or not i'm not here to do that but
i'll tell you that verse condemns
certain hairstyles
but there's a holy spirit that convicts
you if you're genuine with god
go to first peter chapter three
we read from verse one
first peter three reading from verse one
have you found that
no some people are still looking
all right we'll wait patience is a
virtue we'll wait
you have five seconds
you have it now
read with me
likewise you wise be in subjection to
your own husbands if any obey not the
word they also may without the word be
won by the conversation of the wife
while they behold your chaste
conversation coupled with fear let me
explain that what peter is telling women
who married to unconverted men
don't like the man
let him see your holy life and that you
still respect him as your husband let
him see that
and that will win him
don't insist he comes to church he's an
adult don't badger him until he seeks
mental help
leave the man alone
just be faithful to god
respect him as your husband and that
will do the work all right now
they also made without the word be one
by the consciousness of the why why they
behold your chaste conversation coupled
with fear read verse three who's
adorning let it not be that outward the
dawning of
letting the hair again or oh
or of putting on of a power meaning very
expensive clothes verse four but let it
be the hidden man of the heart in that
which is not corruptable so we have
corruptable in verse four then what is
corruptable what is in verse three
read verse 3 again
who's the dawning let it not be that
outward the dawning of
uh or
wearing of gold or putting off apparel
expensive clothes gold all the weaves
whatever people do
that is corruptable meaning it passes
away verse 4 says but let it be the
hidden man of the heart in that which is
not corruptable even the ornament of a
meek and quiet spirit which in the sight
of god is of great price watson number
three is of no value to god
what's the number four is of great value
to god
and your child of god your first
interest is what is important to god now
read verse five interesting verse for
after this manner
all time the holy women also who trusted
in god adorned themselves stop
that's how the holy women of the old
conducted themselves
modestly
that's what the bible says
now let me finish on jury with this go
to matthew not matthew revelation 12.
i know the subject is not popular i know
that
you're as quiet as a graveyard okay
revelation 12.
do you have revelation 12.
let's read the first one read with me
and they appeared a great wonder in
heaven a woman clawed of the sun and the
moon under her feet and upon her head a
crown of twelve stars stopped describe
how this woman is adorned how is she
described
clothed with the sun what does the sun
give
light
what were adam and eve surrounded by
before they sinned light keep reading
the moon under her feet what does the
moon give
light and upon a head a crown of 12
stars what do the stars give light when
were they made genesis 1 sun moon and
stars one of their reasons was let them
be for signs for seasons for days and
years and let them be for light in the
firmament of the earth to give light
upon the earth she is adorned in the
light
go to revelation 17.
let's look at another woman
you have revelation 17
let's reverse fort what does that say
the woman
was arrayed in purple and scarlet color
and decked with gold precious stone and
pearl what do you understand by date
there's a word the rap world gave us
bling are you following me
watch out now
from the rap world gave us bling
i mean the woman in revelation 17 she is
bling bling it used to be bling bling
then they shorten it to bling that's
what describes her she was dead
i
couldn't walk straight so heavy with
jewelry
now listen to me carefully
the one in 12 is adorned in the light of
christ
the one in 17
with all the precious tones and jewelry
the one in 12 represents god's through
church
the one in 17 the corrupt church
you choose which one you'd like to look
like when you dress
i'm not telling you you choose
now let's get off this unpleasant
subject what's the next question i